[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
prévention des risques industriels ne
pas baisser la garde
le 26 septembre 2019 un incendie survenu
dans les usines lubrizol et normandie
logistique à rouen suscitait
l'inquiétude des habitants de
l'agglomération rouennaise
dans un rapport remis le 26 janvier 2022
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
examiné l'ensemble des mesures prises
par le gouvernement depuis l'accident
son bilan
bien mais peut mieux faire
les conclusions présentées par pascal
martin rapporteur s'appuie sur un cycle
d'auditions engagé à la rentrée 2021
elle vise à exercer un droit de suite
aux travaux de la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale constitué en octobre 2019
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
salue les principales évolutions
positives intervenus dans notre
législation en particulier en ce qui
concerne la prévention du risque
incendie
mais il ne faut pas baisser la garde
avertit pascal martin
moyennant de nouvelles modifications
législatives importantes
il s'agit de construire de nouveaux
équilibres permettant de concilier les
impératifs de protection de
l'environnement de prévention des
risques de souveraineté économique et de
développement industriel
dans la continuité des travaux de la
commission denquête les sénateurs ont
adopté huit recommandations
complémentaires s'inscrivant dans quatre
axes
le rapport préconise d'améliorer la
prévention des accidents industriels
à cet effet il est jugé nécessaire
d'augmenter les contrôles réalisés par
l'inspection des installations classées
pour la protection de l'environnement
il convient parallèlement de renforcer
l'information et d'assurer une meilleure
participation du public à la prévention
et à la gestion des risques industriels
en outre la commission souhaite que des
améliorations soient apportées en
matière d'évaluation environnementale de
traitement et de réparation des dommages
résultant d'un accident industriel
enfin le rapport préconise de définir un
système et des procédures permettant
d'assurer un suivi sanitaire efficace
des populations touchées par un accident
industriel
approuvée à l'unanimité par là
commission
ces recommandations complémentaires
pourront être traduite dans le cadre
d'une proposition de loi
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]